c'est inadmissible lui et ça ça doit
plus se reproduire ah non jamais
évidemment je vous dirai ça nous fait de
la peine
tu me dire ça ne monte pas ce que je
vais solide en effet fini je suis bien
je vais finir d'abord faux nom mais nous
leur disons dorénavant non il est temps
nous promet un dispositif
ça sera à l'autodéfense bien sûr ça
c'est le message à l'état le jour on
sera dans l'auto défense
c'est moi qui décide ici tout est dit je
vous le dis c'est pas le moment de dire
ça non pas des mini voilà l'état evo
faire il faut pas se faire justice vous
mais moi je vous le dis attention ces
résultats devant ça vient menacer le
montois se défend tout le monde est
soulagé les gens gratuit des fois on
aurait l'air de l'état l'état a déjà
pris ses dispositions le restaurant de
monsieur est fermé bien sûr fallu la
pression me dire un mot s'il vous plaît
l'état après ses dispositions le
restaurant est fermé moi je suis député
de la ville j'ai porté plainte pour que
la justice soit faite rapidement parce
que justement je ne veux pas que ça
dégénère
donc votre et son coactionnaire c'est de
lutter contre le racisme oui monsieur et
joxi il faut que tu es sûr que ça
dégénère pas où je suis aussi là pour ça
mais moi je suis là pour défendre les
nôtres qui sont victimes
et ça fait trop mais ce système c'est la
faute de l'état français la colonisation
mais non la déshumanisation
les blacks fait c'est ou ça casse
pourquoi quitter ce cas la
responsabilité qui se passe dans le vide
effectivement c'est pour ça qu'on a
porté plainte rapidement il faut que la
police arrête hommes et qu'ils soient
fermement qu'on a déjà su réveiller
colère jusque là il ne faut pas ça veut
dire j'entends votre compagnie le
racisme mais neil nomadiser pas la
colère cergy c'est une ville où tout le
monde vit bien mais c'est ça il faut
devenir communauté qui s'opposent et moi
c'est une vieille ma joie de communes
chose que nous ayons coller avec 157
nationalité avec tout ça fait déjà
sensation de combat entre communautés
secours n'est pas de tomber nous le cas
et sont déjà si nous font tant que
député joue en tant que député du val
d'oise week avez vous déjà proposé pour
lutter contre la négrophobie au sol et
mes photos déclaré monsieur vous êtes
tombé sur le bon député ou à l'inversé
une question de jours ou gagner contre
le racing est déposée encore la semaine
dernière une proposition grave n'est pas
là pour savoir défi l'extrême droite je
fais 516 et je vais vous dire cergy est
une ville qui m'a beaucoup appris en
termes de vivre ensemble de solidarité
autres n'importer pas des combattants
dans ce new deal purcell et appeler au
calme
je vais vous dire ce soir s'il ya des
jeunes qui n'auraient rien n'a beaucoup
qui nous regardent ce soit ce soir on
veut pas d'image comme ça on veut pas
mal de séquences correctement à cergy où
j'ai plein d'amis qui avaient que pour
qui ça se passe très bien où toutes les
communautés vivent ensemble ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est un appel au calme exercée sur
crouch
c'est dramatique non mais je veux dire
gucci nous on ne veut pas de cette
société là mais les gens comme dans les
six mois tout a été dit il cette dame
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé pour le
livreur on ne veut pas de scène un corps
aussi était là on ne veut pas d'
escalade de la violence
on aimerait vraiment que tout le monde
puisse se réunir qu'on puisse avoir les
responsables et le responsable sur
évident qu'on arrête exactement et qu'il
soit puni parce que je vous dire ça
c'est inadmissible quand je vous disais
que ça me fait de la peine et gucci sait
pas c'est que c'est que ça me fait de la
peine pour la société de voir une
société comme ça ça fait de la peine à
tout le monde parce que c'est parce
qu'on veut bien sûr est que mes propos
ni a proféré ce jeu de ce set c'est cet
abruti phospho 6 à in amenas